ا
الله اكبر
الله اكبر اشهد ان لا اله الا
الله اشهد ان
محمدا رسول
الله حي على
الصلا حي على
الفلاح قد قامت الصلاه
قد قامت
الصلاه الله اكبر
الله اكبر
لا اله الا
الله استقيموا اعتدلوا استو سو الصف سدوا
الخلل اقيموا
صفوفكم
الله
اكبر الحمد لله رب
العالمين الرحمن الرحيم مالك يوم
الدين اياك نعبد واياك
نستعين اهدنا الصراط
المستقيم صراط الذين انعمت عليهم غير
المغضوب عليهم ولا
الضالين
امين ولوطا اذ قال لقومه تاتون الفاحشه
وانتم
تبصرون ا انكم لتاتون الرجال شهوه من دون
النساء بل انتم قوم
تجهلون فما كان جواب قومه الا ان قالوا
اخرجوا ال لوط من قريتكم
انهم اناس
يتطهرون
فانجيناه ومن
فانجيناه واهله الا
امراته الا امراته
قدرناها من
الغابرين
وامطرنا عليهم
مطرا
فساء مر
المنذرين قل الحمد لله وسلام على عباده
الذين
اصطفى
ا الله خير اما
يشركون امن خلق السماوات والارض وانزل
لكم
وانزل لكم من
السماء
ماء
فانبتنا
فانبتنا به
حدائق ذات
بهجه ما كان
لكم ما كان لكم ان
تنبتوا
شجرها
اههم مع
الله بل هم قوم
يعدلون
امن جعل الارض قرارا وجعل خلالها
انهارا وجعل لها رواسي وجعل بين البحرين
حاجزا
االه مع
الله بل اكثرهم لا
يعلمون ام من يجيب المضطر اذا
دعاه ويكشف
السوء ويجعلكم
خلفاء الارض
اى مع
الله
قليلا ما
تذكرون
امن يهديكم في ظ ظلمات البر والبحر ومن
يرسل ومن يرسل الرياح بشرا بين يدي
رحمته
اه مع
الله تعالى الله عما
يشركون
ام يبدا الخلق ثم يعيده ومن
يرزقكم ومن
يرزقكم من
السماء والارض
اه مع
الله قل هاتوا
برهانكم قل هاتوا برهانكم ان كنتم
صادقين قل لا يعلم من
السماوات والارض ومن في الارض قل لا يعلم
من في السماوات والارض الغيب الا
الله وما يشعرون ايان
يبعثون بل ادارك علمهم في الاخره بل هم في
شك
منها بل
هم منها عمود
وقال الذين كفروا ائذا
كنا ترابا
واباؤنا
اانا
لمخرجون لقد وعدنا هذا نحن
واباؤنا ان هذا الا اساطير الاولين
لقد
وعدنا لقد وعدنا هذا نحن
واباؤنا من قبل ان
هذا ان هذا الا اساطير
الاولين قل سيروا في الارض
فانظروا كيف كان عاقبه
المجرمين ولا تحزن عليه
ولا تحزن عليهم ولا تكن في ضيق
مما
يمكرون وان ربك لذو فضل على
الناس ويقولون متى هذا الوعد ان كنتم
صادقين وان ربك لذو فضل على
الناس قل عسى ان يكون ردف لكم بعض الذي
تستعجلون وان ربك لذو فضل على
الناس
ولكن اكثرهم لا
يشكرون الله اكبر
سمع الله لمن
حمده الله
اكبر الله
[Silence]
اكبر
الله
اكبر الحمد لله رب
العالمين الرحمن الرحيم مالك يوم الدين
اياك نعبد واياك
نستعين اهدنا الص صراط المستقيم صراط
الذين انعمت
عليهم غير المغضوب عليهم ولا
الضالين
امين وان ربك لذو فضل على الناس ولكن
اكثرهم لا يشكرون
وان ربك ليعلم ما ما تكن صدورهم وما
يعلنون وما من
غائبه في
السماء وما من
السماء والارض الا في كتاب
مبين ان هذا القر القران يقص على بني
اسرائيل ان هذا القران يقص على بني
اسرائيل اكثر الذي هم فيه
يختلفون وانه لهدى ورحمه
للمؤمنين ان ربك يقضي بينهم بحكم وهو
العزيز
العليم فتوكل على
الله
انك على الحق
المبين
انك لا تسمعوا الموتى ولا تسمعوا
الصم
الدعاء اذا ولوا
مدبرين وما انت بهادي العمي عن ضلال
ان تسمع الا من يؤمن
باياتنا
فهم
مسلمون الله
اكبر سمع الله لمن حمده
الله
اكبر الله
اكبر الله اكبر
[Silence]
الله
اكبر بسم الله
الرحمن
[Silence]
الله
اكبر سمع الله لمن
حمده
الله
اكبر الله
اكبر
الله
[Silence]
اكبر سمع
الله من
حمده الله
اكبر الله
اكبر الله الله
[Silence]
اكبر
سلام عليكم ورحمه
الله السلام عليكم ورحمه
الله
[Silence]
لامكم
‏something
[Silence]
take
‏comm ‏he right here those of you don't
know him he very shy pleas i just want
and saying that with the love and
passion and gra to my brother and his
family and i know he does not want us to
to talk or say to much about it but i
want to let you know brother and sisters
we are really blessed to have brothers
him in our community he has put us
on the
m now this
[Silence]
‏new
‏gu
other
soing just
like
are
question
‏there ses of that exit you see pi
describes where this expansion going to
be
just pictorial going be the left side my
side other side
of gum and there sps as walk in the
paring l outside and that's take struc
two st
in again
ask be for
this and just think don that just want
you
think not gener gener
‏gener m
generation and
this re com every you donate this pro so
we are bl to have opp i excit about that
and just want to say
that this
‏back every person
house given so person 12 person that be
given
and don to
some
make
‏and i
think
so me
regrow
and the
those so
[Silence]
حك استقيموا اعتدلوا
استووا الله
اكبر الله
الحمد لله رب
العالمين الرحمن الرحيم مالك يوم
الدين اياك نعبد واياك
نستعين اهدنا الصراط
المستقيم صراط الذين انعمت عليهم غير غير
المغضوب عليهم ولا
الضالين
امين واذا وقع القول عليهم اخرجنا لهم
دابه من الارض
تكلمهم تكلمهم ان الناس كانوا باياتنا لا
يوقنون ويوم نحشر من كل
امه فوجا ممن يكذب
باياتنا فهم
يوزعون حتى اذا
جاءوا قال اكذبتم
باياتي ولم تحيطوا بها
علما
اما ماذا كنتم
تعملون ووقع القول عليهم بما ظلموا فهم لا
ينطقون الم يروا انا جعلنا الليل ليسكنوا
فيه والنهار
مبصرا ان في ذلك لايات لقوم
يؤمنون ويوم ينفخ في الصور ففزع من في
السماوات ومن في الارض
الا الا من
شاء
الله وكل اتوه
داخرين وترى الجبال تحسبها
جامده وهي تمر مر
السحاب صنع الله الذي اتقن كل شيء اتقن كل
شيء صنع الله الذي اتقن كل شيء انه خبير
بما
تعملون انه خبير بما
تفعلون من جاء بالحسنه فله خير منها وهم
من
فزع يومئذ
امنون ومن جاء بالسيئه فكبت وجوههم في
النار هل تجزون الا ما كنتم
تعملون انما امرت ان اعبد رب هذه البلده
الذي
حرمها وله كل شيء
وامرت ان اكون من
المسلمين وان اتلو
القران فمن اهتدى
فانما يهتدي لنفسه ومن ضل فقل
انما انا من
المنذرين وقل الحمد لله سيريكم اياته
فتعرفونها
وما ربك بغافل
عما
تعملون بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم طا
س
م تلك ايات الكتاب
المبين نتلو عليك من نبا موسى وفرعون
بالحق لقوم
يؤمنون ان فرعون على في الارض وجعل اهلها
شيعا يستضعف
طائفه
منهم يذبح
ابناءهم ويستحيي
نساءهم
انه كان من
المفسدين نريد ان نمن على الذين استضعفوا
في الارض ونجعلهم
ائ ونجعلهم
ائمه ونجعلهم
الوارثين ونمكن لهم في الارض ونري فرعون
وهامان
وجنودهما ونري فرعون وهاما
وجنودهما منهم ما كانوا
يحذرون واوحينا الى ام موسى ان
ارضعيه فاذا خفت عليه فالقيه في اليم ولا
تخافي ولا تخافي ولا
تحزني
انا
ردوه الي وجاعلوه من
المرسلين فالتقطه ال فرعون ليكون لهم عدوا
وحزنا ان فرعون وهامان وجنوده ما كانوا
خاطئين وقالت امراه فرعون قره عين لي ولك
لا
تقتلوه لا تقتلوه عسى ان
ينفعنا او نتخذه ولدا او نتخذه ولدا وهم
لا
يشعرون واصبح فواد ام موسى
فارغا واصبح فؤاد ام موسى فارغا ان كادت
لتبدي بها به لولا ان ربطنا على
قلبها لتكون من
المؤمنين الله
اكبر سمع الله لمن
حمده
الله اكبر الله
اكبر الله
[Silence]
اكبر
الله
اكبر الحمد لله رب
العالمين الرحمن الرحيم مالك يوم الدين
اياك نعبد واياك
نستعين اهدنا الصراط
المستقيم صراط الذين انعمت
عليهم غير المغضوب عليهم ولا
الضالين
امين وقالت لاخته
قصيه فبصرت به عن
جنب وهم لا
يشعرون
وحرمنا عليه المراضع من قبل
فقالت فقالت هل ادلكم على اهل بيت
يكفلونه لكم وهم له
حافظون وهم له
ناصحون فرددناه الى امه كي تقر عينها ولا
تحزن ولتعلم ان وعد الله حق
ولكن اكثرهم لا
يعلمون ولما بلغ اشده
واستوى اتيناه
حكما
وعلما وكذلك نجزي
المحسنين فدخل المدينه على حين
غفله من
اهلها ودخل المدينه ودخل المدينه على حين
اهلها فوجد فيها رجلين
يقتتلان هذا من شيعته وهذا من عدوه
فاستغاثه الذي من شيعته على الذي من عدوه
فوكزه
موسى فوكزه
موسى فقضى
عليه قال هذا من عمل الشيطان انه عدو مضل
مبين قال رب اني ظلمت نفسي فاغفر لي فاغفر
له
انه هو الغفور
الرحيم قال رب بما انعمت علي فلن اكون
ظهيرا
للمجرمين فاصبح في المدينه
خائفا
يترقب فاذا الذي
استنصره بالامس
يستصرخه قال له موسى انك
لغوي مبين فلما ان اراد ان يبطش بالذي هو
عدو
لهما قال يا موسى اتريد ان تقتلني كما
قتلت نفسا
بالامس ان تريد الا ان تكون
جبارا في الارض وما تريد ان تكون من
المصلحين وجاء رجل من اقصى المدينه يسعى
قال يا موسى ان الملا ياتمرون بك
ليقتلوك فاخرج اني لك من
الناصحين فخرج منها
خائفا
يترقب قال رب نجني من القوم
الظالمين
ولما
توجهت قاء مدين قال عسى ربي ان يهديني
سواء
السبيل
ولما ورد ماء مدين وجد عليه
ام وجد عليه
امه من الناس
يسقون ووجد من دونهم امراتين تذو
قال ما
خطبكما قال تلا نسقي حتى يصدر
الرعاء وابونا شيخ كبير فسقى لهما ثم تولى
الى الظل
فقال فقال رب اني لما انزلت الي من خير
فقير فجا جاءته احداهما
تمشي
فجاءته احداهما تمشي على
استحياء قالت قالت ان ابي يدعوك ليجزيك
اجر ما سقيت لنا فلما
جاءه وقص عليه القصص
قال قال لا تخف نجوت من القوم
الظالمين قالت احداهما يا ابت
استاجره ان خير من استاجرت القوي الامين
قال اني اريد ان انكحك احدى ابنتي هاتين
على على ان تاجرني ثماني حجج فان اتممت
عشرا فمن عندك وما اريد ان اشق
عليك ستجدني ان
شاء الله من
الصالحين قال ذلك بيني وبينك ايما الاجلين
قضيت فلا عدوان
علي وال الله على ما نقول
وكيل الله
اكبر سمع الله لمن
حمده الله
اكبر
الله
اكبر الله
اكبر
الله
[Silence]
‏no
السلام عليكم ورحمه
الله السلام عليكم ورحمه
[Silence]
الله
‏ok
[Silence]
استقيم
واستو
رات يا
رب الله
اكبر بسم الله الرحمن
الرحيم الحمد لله رب
العالمين الرحمن
الرحيم مالك يوم
الدين اياك نعبد واياك
نستعين اهد ادنا الصراط
المستقيم صراط الذين انعمت عليهم غير
المغضوب عليهم ولا
الضالين
امين فلما قضى موسى الاجل وسار باهله انس
من جانب الطور
نارا قال لاهلهم
كثواب نارا لعلي
اتيكم منها بخبر او جذوه من النار لعلكم
تصطلون فلما اتاها نودي من شاطئ الوادي
الايمن في البقعه المباركه من الشجره ان
يا موسى اني الله رب
العالمين وان الق عصاك فلما راها تهتز
كانها
جان ولا مدبرا ولم
يعقب يا موسى اقبل ولا تخف انك من
الامنين وادخل يدك في جيبك تخرج بيضا
من غير
سوء واضمم اليك جناحك من
الرهب اسلك يدك في جيبك تخرج
بيضاء من غير
سوء واضمم اليك جناحك من الرهب فذلك
برهانان من ربك الى فرعون وملاه انهم
كانوا قوما فاسقين
قال رب اني قتلت منهم نفسا فاخاف ان
يقتلون واخي هارون هو افصح مني لسانا
فارسله مع يرد ان يصدقني اني اخاف ان
يكذبون قال سنشد عضدك باخيك ونجعل لكما
سلطان
فلا يصلون
اليكما
باياتنا انتما ومن اتبعكم
الغالبون فلما
جاءهم موسى
باياتنا
بينات قالوا ما هذا الا سحر
مفترى قالوا ما هذا الا سحر مفتر وما سمع
ع عنا بهذا في
ابائنا
الاولين وقال موسى ربي اعلم بمن جاء
بالهدى من عنده ومن تكون له عاقبه
الدار انه لا يفلح
الظالمون وقال فرعون يا ايها الملا ما
علمت لكم من اله غيري فاوقد لي يا هامان
على الطين فاجعل لي
صرحا فاجعل لي صرحا لعلي اطلع الى اله
موسى واني
لاظنه من
الكاذبين واستكبر هو وجنوده في الارض بغير
الحق وظنوا انهم الينا لا
يرجعون اخذناه وجنوده
فنبذناهم في اليم فانظر كيف كان عاقبه
الظالمين وجعلناهم
ائ يدعون الى النار ويوم القيامه لا
ينصرون
واتبعناهم في هذه الدنيا لعنه ويوم
القيامه هم من المقبوحين
الله
اكبر سمع الله لمن
حمده الله
اكبر الله
اكبر
الله
اكبر بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم الحمد لله رب
العالمين الرحمن الرحيم مالك يوم الدين
اياك نعبد واياك
نستعين اهدنا الصراط المستقيم صراط الذين
انعمت عليهم غير المغضوب عليهم ولا
الضالين
امين ولقد اتينا موسى الكتاب من بعد ما
اهلكنا القرون الاولى
بصائر للناس وهدى ورحمه لعلهم
يتذكرون وما كنت بجانب الغربي اذ قضينا
الى موسى الامر وما كنت من
الشاهدين
ولكنا انشانا قرونا فتطاول عليهم العمر
وما كنت ثاويا في اهل مدين تتلوا عليهم
اياتنا
ولكنا كنا
مرسلين وما كنت بجانب الطور اذ نادينا
ولكن رحمه من ربك لتنذر قوما ما اتاهم من
نذير من قبلك لعلهم
يتذكرون ولو لا ان تصيبهم
مصيبه بما قدمت ايديهم فيقولوا ربنا لولا
ارسلت الينا رسولا فنتبع اياتك ونكون من
المؤمنين فلما
جاءهم الحق من
عندنا قالوا لولا اوتي مثلما اوتي موسى
اولم يكفروا بما اوتي موسى من قبل قالوا
سحران تظاهرا وقالوا انا بكل
كافرون قل فاتوا بكتاب من عند الله هو
اهدى منهما اتبعه ان كنتم
صادقين فان لم يستجيبوا لك ف علم انما
يتبعون
اهواءهم ومن اضل منن اتبع هواه بغير هدى
من الله ان الله لا يهدي القوم
الظالمين الله
اكبر سمع الله لمن
حمده الله
اكبر الله
[Silence]
اكبر
الله
[Silence]
اكبر
السلام عليكم ورحمه الله السلام عليكم
ورحمه
[Silence]
الله
‏po
بسم الله الرحمن
[Silence]
الرحيم بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم الحمد لله
رب العالمين والصلاه والسلام على رسول
الله وعلى اله وصحبه ومنوه ومن تبع باحسان
يوم الدين اما بعد ان شاء
الله عليه
واللام
عشه
[Silence]
خ
‏ops
ops عليه
الهلام عليهه والسلام
‏was
af
heared see this vision you know not
normal you know yourself emp place
and me you are are
there of be youing things so those the
two m reasons they said
[Silence]
عليهه
‏people
[Silence]
عليه مو ع عليهه
والسلام عليه الصلاه والسلام
[Silence]
عليه
صل so this is one this is fur on
continue into detail on it
[Silence]
ئه
رضي عن عليهه
والسلام عليه الصلاه
واللام
[Silence]
الله
‏me الله
[Silence]
عليه الهلام
شاء
علول
صلال
عليهه
[Silence]
سالانى
الحلا اله الا الله محمد رسول الله الله
سبحانه لا اله محمد رسول الله ربنا اتنا
في الدنيا حسنه وفي الاخره حسنه وقنا عذا
النار وقنا عذا القبر وقنا عذاب جهنم ونا
ع فتنه المحيا والمات وقنا ع فتنه المسيح
الدجال ربنا اغفر لنا ولوالدينا والمسلمين
والمسلمات والمؤمنين والمؤمنات الاحياء من
الاموات ربنا تقبل منك انت السميع العليم
توب علينا يا مولانا تواب الرحيم وصلى
الله على محمد وعلى اله وصحبه اجمعين
برحمتك ارحم الراحمين اللهم امين اللهم
امين اللهم
امينك بسم الله الرحمن
الرحيم
استقيم
الله
اكبر بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم الحمد لله رب
العالمين الرحمن
الرحيم مالك يوم
الدين اياك نعبد واياك نستعين اهدنا
الصراط
المستقيم صراط الذين انعمت عليهم غير الم
المغضوب عليهم ولا
الضالين
امين ولقد وصلنا لهم القول لعلهم
يتذكرون الذين اتيناهم الكتاب من قبله هم
به
يؤمنون واذا يتلى عليهم قالوا امنا به ان
انه الحق من ربنا انا كنا من قبله
مسلمين
اولئك يؤتون اجرهم مرتين بما صبروا
ويدرؤون بالحسنه السيئه ومما رزقناهم
ينفقون واذا سمعوا اللغو اعرضوا عنه
وقالوا لنا اعمالنا ولكم اعمال م سلام
عليكم لا نبتغي
الجاهلين انك لا تهدي من احببت
ولكن الله يهدي من
يشاء وهو اعلم بالمهتدين
وقالوا ان نتبع الهدى معك نتخطف من ارضنا
اولم نمكن لهم حرما امنا يجب اليه ثمرات
كل شيء رزقا من لدنا ولكن اكثرهم لا
يعلمون وكم اهلكنا من قريه بطرت معيشتها
فتلك مساكنهم لم تسكن من بعدهم الا قليلا
وكنا نحن
الوارثين وما كان ربك مهلك القرى حتى يبعث
في ام بها رسولا يتلوا عليهم
اياتنا وما كنا مهلك القرى الا واهلها
ظالمون وما اوتيتم من شيء فمتاع الحياه
الدنيا
وزينتها وما عند الله خير وابقى افلا
تعقلون افمن وعدناه وعدا حسنا
فهو لاقيه كمن متعناه متاع الحياه الدنيا
ثم هو يوم القيامه من
المحضرين ويوم يناديهم فيقول اين
شركائي الذين كنتم
تزعمون قال الذين حق عليهم القول ربنا
هؤلاء الذين اغوينا اغويناهم كما
غوينا تبرانا اليك ما كانوا ايانا
يعبدون وقيل ادعوا شهداء وقيل ادعوا
شركاءكم فدعوهم فلم يستجيبوا لهم وراوا
العذاب لو انهم كانوا
يهتدون ويوم يناديهم فيقول ماذا اجبتم
المرسلين
فعميت عليهم
الانباء يومئذ فهم لا
يتساءلون فاما من تاب وامن وعمل صالحا
فعسى ان يكون من
المفلحين وربك يخلق ما يشاء ويختار ما كان
لهم الخيره سبحان الله وتعالى عما ي
شكون وربك يعلم ما تكن صدورهم وما يعلنون
وهو الله لا اله الا هو له الحمد في
الاولى والاخره وله الحكم واليه
ترجعون قل ارايتم ان جعل الله عليكم الليل
سرمدا الى يوم القيامه من اله غير الله
ياتيكم بضياء
افلا
تسمعون قل ارايتم ان جعل الله عليكم
النهار سرمدا الى يوم القيامه من اله غير
الله ياتيكم بليل تسكنون فيه افلا
تبصرون ومن رحمته جعل لكم الليل
والنهار لتسكنوا فيه ولتبتغوا من من فضله
ولعلكم تشكرون ويوم يناديهم فيقول اين
شركائي الذين كنتم
تزعمون ونزعنا من كل امه شهيدا فقلنا
هاتوا
برهانكم فعلموا ان الحق لله وضل
عنهم ما كانوا
يفترون
الله
اكبر سمع الله لمن
حمده الله
اكبر الله
اكبر الله اكبر
[Silence]
الله
اكبر بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم الحمد لله رب
العالمين الرحمن الرحيم مالك يوم الدين
ايا اياك نعبد واياك
نستعين اهدنا الصراط المستقيم صراط الذين
انعمت عليهم غير المغضوب عليهم ولا
الضالين
امين ان قارون كان من قوم موسى فبغى عليهم
واتيناه من الكنوز ما ان مفاتحه
لتنوء بالعصبه اولي
القوه اذ قال له قومه لا تفرح ان الله لا
يحب
الفرحين وابتغ فيما اتاك الله الدار
الاخره ولا تنسى نصيبك من الدنيا واحسن
كما احسن الله اليك واحسن كما احسن الله
اليك ولا تبغي الفساد في الارض ان الله لا
يحب
المفسدين قال انما اوتيته على علم
عندي اولم يعلم ان الله قد اهلك من قبله
من القرون من هو اشد منه قوه واكثر
جمعا ولا يسال عن عن ذنوبهم
المجرمون فخرج على قومه في زينته قال
الذين يريدون الحياه الدنيا يا ليت لنا
مثل ما اوتي قارون انه لذو حظ
عظيم وقال الذين اوتوا العلم ويلكم ثواب
الله خير لمن امن وعمل صالحا ولا يلقاها
الا
صابرون فخسفنا به وبداره الارض فما كان له
من فئه
ينصرونه من دون الله وما كان من
المنتصرين واصبح الذين تمنوا مكانه بالامس
يقولون ويك ان الله يبسط الرزق لمن
يشاء من عباده وي
لولا
انن الله علينا لخسف بنا وي
كانه لا يفلح
الكافرون تلك الدار الاخره نجعلها للذين
لا يريدون علوا في الارض ولا
فسادا والعاقبه
للمتقين من
جاء بالحسنه فله خير منها ومن
جاء بالسيئه فلا يجزى الذين عملوا السيئات
الا ما كانوا
يعملون ان الذي فرض عليك القران
لرادك الى معاد قل ربي اعلم من
جاء بالهدى ومن هو في ضلال
مبين وما كنت ترجو ان يلقى اليك الكتاب
الا رحمه من ربك فلا تكونن ظهيرا
للكافرين ولا
يصدنك عن ايات الله بعد اذ انزلت اليك
وادع الى ربك ولا
تكونن من
المشركين ولا تدع مع الله
الها اخر لا اله الا هو كل شيء هالك الا
وجهه له الحكم واليه
ترجعون الله
اكبر سمع الله لمن
حمده الله
اكبر
الله
[Silence]
السلام عليكم ورحمه الله
السلام عليكم ورحمه
الله
اكبر بسم الله الرحمن
الرحيم الحمد لله رب
العالمين الرحمن
الرحيم مالك يوم
الدين اياك نعبد واياك
نستعين اهدنا الصراط
المستقيم صراط الذين انعمت عليهم غير
المغضوب عليهم ولا
الضالين
امين
الم
م احسب الناس ان يتركوا ان يقولوا امنا
وهم لا
يفتنون ولقد فتنا الذين من قبلهم
فليعلمن الله الذين صدقوا وليعلمن
الكاذبين ام حسب الذين يعملون السيئات ان
يسبقونا
ساء ما
يحكمون من كان يرجو لقاء الله فان اجل
الله لا وهو السميع
العليم ومن جاهد فانما يجاهد لنفسه ان
الله لغني
عن
العالمين والذين امنوا وعملوا الصالحات
لنكفرن عنهم سيئاتهم
ولنجزينهم احسن الذي كانوا
يعملون ووصينا الانسان بوالديه حسنا وان
جاهداك لتشرك بيما ليس لك به علم فلا
تطعهما الي مرجع
فانبذ بما كنتم
تعملون والذين امنوا وعملوا الصالحات
لندخلنهم في
الصالحين ومن الناس من يقول امنا بالله
فاذا اوذي في الله جعل فتنه
الناس كعذاب
الله ولئن جاء نصر من رب ك ليقولن انا كنا
معكم اوليس الله باعلم بما في صدور
العالمين
وليعلمن الله الذين امنوا
وليعلمن
المنافقين وقال الذين كفروا للذين امنوا
اتبعوا سبيلنا ولنحمل
خطاياكم وما هم بح ين من
خطاياهم من شيء انهم
لكاذبون
وليحملن اثقالهم
واثقالا مع اثقالهم
وليسن يوم القيامه عما كانوا
يفترون ولقد ارسلنا نوحا الى قومه فلبث
فيهم الف سنه الا 50
فاخذهم الطوفان وهم
ظالمون
فانجيناه واصحاب السفينه
وجعلناها ايه
للعالمين وابراهيم اذ قال لقومه اعبدوا
الله واتقوه ذلكم خير لكم ان كنتم
تعلمون انما تعبدون من دون الله اوثانا
وتخلقون افكا ان الذين تعبدون من دون الله
لا يملكون لكم رزقا فابتغوا عند الله
الرزق واعبدوه واشكروا له اليه
ترجعون وان تكذبوا فقد كذب امم من قبلكم
وما على الرسول الا البلاغ
المبين اولم يروا كيف يبدئ كيف يبدئ الله
الخلق ثم يعيده ان ذلك على الله يسير قل
سيروا في الارض فانظروا كيف بدا الخلق ثم
الله ينشئ النشاه الاخره ان الله على كل
شيء قدير يعذب من
يشاء ويرحم من
يشاء واليه
تقلبون وما
انتم بمعجزين في الارض ولا في
السماء وما لكم من دون الله من من ولي وما
لكم من دون الله من ولي ولا
نصير والذين كفروا بايات الله
ولقائه
اولئك يئسوا من رحمتي
واولئك لهم عذاب اليم فما كان جواب قومه
الا ان قالوا اقتلوه او
حرقوه
فانجا الله من
النار ان في ذلك لايات
لقوم
يؤمنون و قال انما اتخذتم من دون الله
اوثانا موده بينكم في الحياه
الدنيا ثم يوم القيامه يكفر بعضكم ببعض
ويلعن بعضكم بعضا وماواهم النار وما لكم
من
ناصرين فامن له لوط وقال اني مهاجر الى
ربي انه هو العزيز
الحكيم ووهبنا له اسحاق ويعقوب وجعلنا في
ذريته النبوه
والكتاب
واتيناه اجره في الدنيا وانه في الاخره
لمن
الصالحين الله
اكبر
سمع الله لمن
حمده الله
اكبر الله
اكبر
الله
اكبر بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم الحمد لله رب
العالمين الرحمن الرحيم مالك يوم
الدين اياك نعبد واياك
نستعين اهدنا الصراط
المستقيم صراط الذين انعمت عليهم غير
المغضوب عليهم ولا
الضالين
امين ولوطا اذ قال
لقومه انكم لتاتون ال فاحشه ما سبقكم بها
من احد من
العالمين ا انكم لتاتون الرجال وتقطعون
السبيل وتاتون في ناديكم المنكر فما كان
جواب قومه الا ان قالوا ائتنا بعذاب الله
ان كنت من
الصادقين قال رب
انصرني على القوم
المفسدين ولما
جاءت رسلنا ابراهيم بالبشرى قالوا انا
مهلكوا اهل هذه القريه ان اهلها كانوا
ظالمين قال ان فيها لوطا قالوا نحن اعلم
بمن فيها
لننجح الا امراته كانت من
الغابرين ولما ان
جاءت رسلنا لوطا سيء بهم وضاق بهم را
وقالوا لا تخف ولا تحزن انا منجوك واهلك
الا امراتك كانت من
الغابرين انا منزلون على اهل هذه القريه
رجزا من السماء بما كانوا يفسقون
ولقد تركنا منها ايه بينه لقوم يعقلون
والى مدين اخاهم شعيبا فقال يا قوم اعبدوا
الله وارجوا اليوم الاخر ولا تعثوا في
الارض
مفسدين فكذبوه فاخذتهم الرجفه فاصبحوا في
دارهم
جاثمين وعادا وثمود وقد تبين لكم من
مساكنهم وزين لهم الشيطان اعمالهم فصدهم
عن السبيل وكانوا
مستبصرين وقارون وفرعون
وهامان ولقد
جاءهم موسى بالبينات فاستكبروا في الارض
وما كانوا
سابقين فكلا اخذنا بذنبه فمنهم من ارسلنا
عليه
حاصبا ومنهم من اخذته الصيحه ومنهم من
خسفنا به الارض ومنهم من
اغرقنا وما كان الله ليظلمهم ولكن كانوا
انفسهم
يظلمون مثل الذين اتخذوا من دون الله
اولياء كمثل العنكبوت اتخذت بيتا وان اوهن
البيوت لبيت
العنكبوت لو كانوا
يعلمون ان الله يعلم ما يدعون من دونه من
شيء وهو العزيز
الحكيم وتلك الامثال نضربها للناس وما
يعقلها الا
العالمون خلق الله السماوات والارض بالحق
ان في ذلك لايه
للمؤمنين اتل ما اوحي اليك من الكتاب واقم
الصلاه ان الصلاه تنهى عن
الفحشاء
والمنكر ولذكر الله اكبر والله يعلم ما
تصنعون الله
اكبر
سمع الله لمن
حمده
الله
اكبر
اكبر الله
الله
[Silence]
اكبر
السلام عليكم ورحمه
الله
استغفر
الله صلاه الوتر
استقيم الله
اكبر
بسم الله الرحمن
الرحيم الحمد لله رب
العالمين الرحمن
الرحيم مالك يوم
الدين اياك نعبد واياك
نستعين اهدنا الصراط المستقيم صراط الذين
انعمت عليهم غير المغضوب عليهم ولا
الضال
امين ان الابرار لفي نعيم وان الفجار لفي
جحيم يصلونها يوم الدين وما هم عنها
بغائبين وما ادراك ما يوم
الدين ثم ما ادراك ما يوم الدين يوم لا تم
نفس لنفس شيئا والامر يومئذ
لله الله
اكبر سمع الله لمن
حمده الله
اكبر الله
اكبر الله الله
اكبر
الله
اكبر بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم الحمد لله رب
العالمين الرحمن الرحيم مالك يوم
الدين اياك نعبد واياك
نستعين اهدنا الصراط المستقيم
صراط الذين انعمت عليهم غير المغضوب عليهم
ولا
الضالين
امين قد افلح من تزكى وذكر اسم ربه فصلى
بل تؤثرون الحياه الدنيا والاخره خير
وابقى ان هذا لفي الصحف الاولى صحف
ابراهيم
وموسى الله
اكبر سمع الله لمن
حمده الله
اكبر
الله
اكبر الله
اكبر
الله
[Silence]
السلام عليكم ورحمه
الله السلام عليكم ورحمه
الله
اكبر بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم الحمد لله رب
العالمين الرحمن
الرحيم مالك يوم
الدين اياك نعبد واياك
نستعين اهدنا الصراط
المستقيم صراط الذين انعمت عليهم غير
المغضوب عليهم ولا
الضالين
امين قل هو الله احد الله الصمد لم يلد
ولم يولد ولم يكن له كفوا
احد الله اكبر
سمع
الله لمن
حمده ربنا لك الحمد حمدا كثيرا طيبا
مباركا فيه اللهم صل على سيدنا محمد وعلى
اله واصحابه
اجمعين اللهم بلغنا ليله القدر اللهم
بلغنا ليله القدر اللهم بلغنا ليله القدر
واجعلنا من
عتقائك من النار ومن
المقبولين
اللهم اجعلنا من عتقائك من النار ومن
المقبولين اللهم اقسم لنا من خشيتك ما
تحول به بيننا وبين معصيتك ومن طاعتك ما
تبلغنا به جنتك ومن اليقين ما تهون به
علينا مصائب الدنيا ومتعنا اللهم باسماعنا
وابصارنا وقوتنا ما احييتنا واجعله الوارث
منا واجعل ثارنا على من ظلمنا وانصرنا على
من عادانا ولا تجعل مصيبتنا في ديننا ولا
تجعل الدنيا اكبر همنا ولا مبلغ علمنا ولا
الى النار مصيرنا ولا تسلط علينا من لا
يخافك ولا
يرحمنا ربنا اتمم لنا نورنا واغفر لنا انك
على كل شيء قدير ربنا ربنا اغفر لنا
ولاخواننا الذين سبقونا بالايمان ولا تجعل
في قلوبنا غلا للذين امنوا ربنا انك رؤوف
رحيم
اللهم انصر اخواننا المستضعفين في كل مكان
في غزه والسودان وغيرهما يا رب العالمين
اللهم اطعمهم من جوع وامنهم من خوف اللهم
انصرهم على عدوك وعدوهم يا رب العالمين
اللهم اهلك الظالمين اللهم اضرب الظالمين
بالظالمين واخرج المسلمين من بينهم
اللهم اقتلهم بددا واحصهم عددا ولا تبق
منهم احدا انهم يا رب لا يعجزونك وصلى
الله وسلم وبارك على نبينا محمد وعلى اله
واصحابه
اجمعين الله
اكبر
الله
[Silence]
اكبر
السلام عليكم ورحمه الله السلام عليكم
ورحمه
الله
سبحان
[Silence]
ان